um this is happening too the nfl is
going to play some games this year and
the players now are slamming the
league's new covid protocols
that put heavy restrictions on
unvaccinated players
some are arguing the players association
the union is not properly representing
them
fox news contributor clay trav is with
us now clay how you doing nice to have
you on the broadcast today and good
morning
where do you come down on this does the
league have it right
or are they missing something here
uh bill and dana thanks for having me on
you guys do great work the league's got
it wrong
uh and look what they're trying to do is
not officially
mandate that everybody get the vaccine
but they're trying to make it so
uncomfortable for the players who don't
get the vaccine
that they basically by default have to
do it in other words they're keeping
restrictions on players
and look the data doesn't support this
by the fall the stadiums are going to be
a hundred percent full there's not going
to be a vaccine requirement for the fans
the players are young and healthy if you
look at all the data they aren't in
danger from covid
if they want to get the vaccine they
should be able to get the vaccine
but trying to force them to get it is
the wrong move by the nfl or any other
disagree with that right here's joe
mixon running back for the bengals
don't get in his way by the way he says
this the league the nfl pa
sorry the union rather is not for the
players they act like they represent us
and they clearly show us different time
and time again
i love everybody and i show love to
everyone vaccinated or not in all caps
he says
i respect everybody who decides to get
the vaccine or not
i'm not against either i will fight and
die for a respected decision
uh to your point though the vaccine
works
and this is the way the nfl
and even major league baseball now
they're not wearing masks in the dugout
as they had been during games for a long
time this is how they encourage other
players
to get the shot i i think that's what's
at work here would you agree
well i don't think i don't think there's
any doubt that's the intent of the nfl
but i would
say there's a difference in sports that
started in the spring the nba
uh certainly which started in the winter
major league baseball which started in
the spring
and where we're going to be bill by the
fall
which is a lot of these players may have
already had covet if you've already got
covered antibodies
what are you going to getting a vaccine
for i just don't think the league itself
should be getting involved let me give
you an example uh bill and dana too
they've never mandated in any way flu
shots right
the flu runs rampant through nfl locker
rooms every season there are major
issues statistically
many young people are under a greater
danger from the flu than they are from
covid
if you are elderly and you're coaching
if you're over 65 you should get the
vaccine
100 because it works but everyone should
analyze their own health risks and also
analyze
whether or not they might have had covet
already and still have the antibodies
from that i just don't think the nfl
should get involved i think joe mixon's
point is a good one
the players association should be by
fighting for
player freedom not allowing the teams to
mandate
effectively this vaccine by putting all
sorts of restrictions
on players who don't make the choices it
just seems to me like the nfl keeps
stepping on it on a rake
every time we do these stories we can
talk about it all the time
clay it was great to see you today thank
you so much hope you come back trey
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now